I was watching this documentary last
night and it had me thinking about maybe
your situation and that is these
filmmakers had been accepted into this
prestigious program and they thought
they just try it and when they got the
letter they almost felt like someone was
playing a joke on them that they got in
yeah absolutely did was that and then
when we were talking off-camera that
that sparked this quite so was that
something that when you applied to leave
you said Hendrix yeah yes oh so
basically I applied to film school kind
of as a a built-in excuse to not pursue
my dreams if that makes sense
so I was just like I'm gonna apply to
I'm gonna apply to USC film school and
no one gets into there so I'm gonna
apply get rejected and then I could say
I tried and then I can go about my life
and I was gonna work it like a like a
gas company in Arkansas like that was
that's what I was gonna do after
graduation and I ended up actually not
doing that and I worked as a youth
director for a little while but so I
applied to USC in the middle of planning
my wedding
basically oh wow and I got a response
one one day like literally an email that
said like the subject line was like RSVP
for admitted students day because I
guess they sent the email in the wrong
order
and I was like admitted students say
what does that mean and then a few
minutes later I got like a admission
decision thing so I found out kind of in
Reverse and I was so confused and I did
I thought someone played a joke on me
and I and I found out I got I got into
USC about two weeks before I was gonna
get married and so I was so stunned and
I was talking to my wife and I was like
so like I'm not gonna go and she's like
no no you have to go and my wife was in
the middle of pharmacy school at the
time so she couldn't just pick up and
leave what she was doing so that meant
like she she pushed me to say yes to
pursue my dreams and so we got married
and then literally two weeks later after
we got married I moved
to Los Angeles to start film school it
was pretty wild yeah but it was amazing
because like it's just a testament to
how awesome my wife is like yeah if she
hadn't have pushed me to say yes to go
pursue your dreams I probably wouldn't
have done it I probably wouldn't have it
didn't how long before she joined you
here so we were part for two years so
for the first two years of film school I
I was just out here by myself in a
long-distance marriage which was pretty
pretty wild but it but it worked out
great Wow that I think that'd be tough
for a lot of people to be separated for
a long time like that and plus you had
you been to Los Angeles before no no I'd
never I'd never been to California at
all so it was like one of those like
almost fish-out-of-water experiences
like I got here and I remember one of
the first things was just showing up at
LAX it was just scary is scary it's
terrifying you're like wait whoa this
one terminal is the size of my entire
Airport where I'm from you know right
and so and you know the cars circle and
you have circling
it's called panic attack circus yeah
exactly exactly and like I I like
stepped out of the airport and suddenly
I was like it felt like I was in a
completely new planet you know and then
no one was weird is that I remember her
when I got to school like I was the
crosswalks in in general like I remember
the crosswalks counted down from 30 and
back where I'm home they count down from
10 and I was like what is this like it's
not take me 30 seconds to get across the
street and in a lot of places it does so
it was just like very strange and I
remember the first time I I parked my
car in the parking deck at USC I didn't
have that skill where you're like okay
let me remember what row I'm on you know
and I I just parked my car and I went to
class and when I came back I couldn't
find my car and me and my friend spent
like four hours in the parking deck
looking for my car and this is like a
you know an eight story parking I've
been
Dec I had no idea where my car was I was
like one of my first experiences out
here and people drive pretty fast too
and that yeah you can die yeah yeah well
the second part of that question goes to
the fact that these same people that
were accepted that thought someone was
playing a joke on them that they got in
then they were in this setting where
they were getting peer feedback mm-hmm
and they had never been through a
process like that before yeah and it was
actually quite upsetting to them totally
yeah it kind of broke people some of
them they absolutely I was just
wandering without maybe you could just
talk in general terms but how that was
to get feedback yeah it's a it's a weird
experience so you know and I and I say
this all with love and stuff for USC cuz
it's it's it's my oh my I love it I love
it with all my heart but the the
feedback process especially in film
school is like unnerving in so many ways
because it's almost like tearing down
people's work is almost like sport
they're like it's like oh yeah you think
you're good we'll check this out and you
know and and at the end of the day it's
all out of love even though it's like
really hard harsh love it's all to make
the work better but I mean coming from
me I never really experienced that
before and I remember the first time we
played my my dailies there was a room of
like 50 people in it and I never forget
this this this one the first comment
that I got somebody raised their hand
and said it doesn't look like this movie
was directed by anybody and I was like
oh oh yeah oh that's what I'm in for
and and the funny part was like they
were kind of right because like I I you
just couldn't tell any intention in my
work at the time you know but like that
was like the tone of how rough the notes
process would be moving forward
throughout school and but at the what's
what's weird is like after that class I
actually went and I cried in the in the
courtyard I I went and I was like I'll
be right back guys
and I went and I wept and I wept
bitterly and I had a moment after I wept
and I realize oh I'm still here I'm
still here I can try again and it seems
like that process sort of it sharpened
me if you will and now I love people's
feedback on my work I love it and now
when people and I've had this I've had
with my with my first feature I've had
people literally walk up to me and say
this is the worst know you've ever seen
I'm like okay that's fine and it doesn't
really bother me anymore cuz like I know
my work ethic I know my intentions as a
director I know what I'm trying to do so
it it helped me in the long run and now
actually I love it because I think the
notes process the feedback process only
sharpens your work and makes it better
if you know what your intention behind
the work is so I love it now well I know
you said that you appreciate USC and I
get it because the people in the
documentary they also said that their
school they still have nothing but
respect for but it was a very
excruciating process and one of the
teachers even said well if you think
this is difficult try being out in the
real world so it was like this sort of
like breeding ground like okay who's
gonna make it who's not and some people
didn't make it and I was wondering how
that was for you because it sounds like
you have a very supportive family and
you came from a supportive College where
you had your four-year degree yeah
mm-hmm
what advice would you give to someone
that's coming here that they know that
this is just part of what they have to
go through it's not intentional they're
not trying to be mean but right yeah
yeah my advice I think would just be did
not quit because it's super easy to get
discouraged and to feel bitter and to
feel like all these people don't get me
they don't you know and stuff like that
but the the great part is that like it
does it does force you to examine
what you're doing to examine your
intention and your work and to sharpen
it so it's the clearest most precise
version of what you're trying to do and
and when you when you realize like when
you when you take your ego out of the
process and you and you go into a note
session thinking like okay I'm just here
to get information that information is
so I can improve my work it's not not
going there to get validation that
you're that you're good at what you do
it's it's not that's not what that
process is for this is like a process of
like whittling you know whittling a
stick into something sharp you know and
then when you're done with that
whittling process then you can you can
sort of release it into the world and
have it be something that you're proud
of hopefully and and that process is so
critical because I when I think about
how I used to work as an artist but as a
creator before my film school experience
I would just like you know if I was
gonna make a short which I made a short
before I went to school and I made one
cut and that was it I was like oh cool
I'm done like I because it's right there
I did it you know but then you realized
that like in film school that's where
you begin that's where the work starts
is on your first try on your first try
where you thought you you crushed it and
you realize oh I actually didn't crush
it at all and that that sense of kind of
humility that comes with the craft is
like a really beautiful place to be in
at least I I feel that way and just I I
now love that process and but it's
unfortunate I actually saw some of my
friends didn't make it through the
program like because like they they were
getting so much harsh feedback I think
they thought they started take it
personally and I started to think like
well nobody gets what I'm doing and so
they dropped out of the program and
that's really unfortunate I mean like
I'm not saying that that's staying and
everybody has their own path so maybe
that was best for them
but when I wanted to quit I'm really
really really grateful that I didn't
because it would have if I would have
quit like right after that note session
where I write wept bitterly I would have
relieved myself of some short-term pain
but I I wouldn't be nearly the filmmaker
than I am right now and and the great
part also about the notes process is it
it sort of it keeps you humble in the
sense that you realize that that there's
so much that you don't know and there's
so much to be explored that like the the
journey of becoming quote a good
filmmaker or a good writer is a lifelong
process
and wherever we are in the process
that's just where you are and I'm
grateful that like I feel like I'm I'm
like just now to the point where I'm
like okay I'm gonna try something new
and I might fail but I've I've gotten
through failure before and I'm still
here
so I know that I can get through it when
I go to your website for your film then
there was Joe I noticed you have a ton
of press from your hometown or from
surrounding areas and they seem so
welcoming of you how is that then to
know that yes when you come to your new
home in LA it's a different ballgame and
it's not personal but it's just there's
so many people doing the same thing so
to be so embraced yeah and and and
cheered on and then coming back here
knowing that you would have to be your
own cheerleader really absolutely yeah
so what's what's interesting about and
like this was like was kind of my
strategy actually for making my first
film I wanted to do it in a place where
be like supported and because the the
crazy part is that kind of anywhere
outside of LA outside of California if
you make a movie like that's newsworthy
you know because it's just not a normal
thing that a lot of people do but out
here in LA everybody's making a movie
like it's and and you know I I
you like use the term everybody but a
whole lot of people are making stuff out
here to the point where it's it's
relatively normalized and like for
instance I I'm whenever I go to a coffee
shop to just get a cup of coffee if you
just look at people's laptops
9 out of 10 screen someone's writing a
screenplay and that is like not normal
anywhere else kind of outside of LA and
so it was amazing we premiered my film
then there was Joe with the Arkansas
cinema Society which is like put on by
Jeff Nichols who directed mud and
Midnight Special and stuff like that so
it was great because like they they saw
my film and and believed in it and so
they were like we're gonna put on a
basically a premiere for it and there
was just a level of excitement that I
just haven't experienced kind of
anywhere else because it was it was a
bit of like a hometown hero kind of vibe
to it but also like people just truly
went to the movies to enjoy themselves I
think sometimes out here in LA we can go
to the movies to judge like that's where
we go I have like we walk in with like
this better impressed me but back home
in Arkansas people like there's like it
was almost like a magic like you walk
into this dark room with all these
strangers and it's like okay what's
gonna happen and and being in that
posture about to watch a film it's like
a totally different vibe and I think
that actually most of the world
experiences movies that way of uh I want
to go and I want to be entertained and I
want to be moved and I want to have fun
and sometimes living out here in LA can
be easy to lose track of that because
sometimes we can try to just impress our
filmmaker friends but like did you see
that dope shot and that thing that was
tight right and but like I knew that
that the film I was making in particular
is for like an audience to consume and
it's for people who live live lives
outside of the energy
industry it's about regular people going
through what they're doing and and
there's redemption at the end and I know
you know sometimes like when I'm
shooting my scripts to friends or they
shoot me their scripts like you know
there's a thing it was like George Lucas
or somebody it said like there's only
like seven plots there's only seven
plots in the world or something like
that and like there's some truth to that
I think like but the just just like how
you can kind of only make a car or kind
of like one way really you know it's
like it usually has four wheels it
sometimes doesn't have to have four
wheels you can make a cart with three
wheels I'm sure but like the reality is
that like I think the majority of people
usually will give a movie a chance in
ways that sometimes like after you've
gone through film school you've already
decided like uh I already I've already
seen this before because I know where
this is going and you're way ahead of
the movie and something you know you can
get into that habit and kind of stop
enjoying films and so what what making
my my feature kind of taught me is it
helped me remember what movies are for
and what they do and what they mean to
me and seeing that in Arkansas was just
a beautiful beautiful experience and it
rejuvenated me and it made me want to
keep going because I got really scared
after I finished my film because I was
so tired I was so exhausted that I was I
had a moment where I was like I don't
think I want to do this anymore
like I think I think I might be one and
done and something happened when the
lights went down and everybody got quiet
and my my movie is a comedy drama into
dramedy if you will but the the first
couple tile cards is a joke and it takes
you a second to get it because it's it
it starts and then there's another title
card and then another and then another
and everybody immediately busted out
laughing and I was like ah they're in
they get it they get it and I showed
that to a lot of my friends out here and
they were like this is dumb
oh really down my god but I knew it was
funny you know and and so I've that's
the other thing it's taught me this
whole process is just like trusting your
voice and knowing that your voice and
your opinion of things how you feel
about something is totally valid and
even if it's standing outside of a group
of people and a group of people don't
agree if you feel strongly about
something there's probably at least a
million other people in the world that
feel the same way and this processed the
notes process and we were talking about
earlier also like just helped me know
when to trust my voice I think you you
said your family has this unofficial
rule I saw this in one of the interviews
that you did I'm taking this from the
paper but if you're afraid of something
that that will make you a stronger
better person that's probably the thing
you need to do right yeah yeah yeah
because like I I think fear is a really
good indicator it's an indicator of
perhaps like your your destiny in a
weird way I don't want to get too new
agey in here but oh and let me turn off
the inside but to me in my brain I feel
like like there's a better side of you
on the other side of fear because like
things I'm not afraid of are things
usually don't they don't mean that much
to me you know I'm usually afraid of the
things that mean the most to me you know
I'm I'm like right before we we launched
my the Kickstarter for my film like I
had never experienced that much fear in
my whole life cuz I was like oh my gosh
this is public if I fail it's gonna be
public everyone's gonna know about it
and like I hesitated for a while and so
there was like a week where I didn't
post it and I was like I don't know if I
can do this right now
and like I thankfully like my my I have
a really supportive family and really
supportive wife and and they're just
like you have to do this like you have
to it's your destiny if you will and and
I and I've noticed that every single
time where I
and utterly terrified and I've pushed
through it I've I've only succeeded and
I don't mean that in like an arrogant
way I mean that in the sense of like I
jumped off the cliff and suddenly a
trampoline appeared right before I
smacked the ground and that has happened
so many times and and I think for anyone
who's put together a feature film like
like you guys you you understand that
you know that like those things happen
you kind of move before any of the
pieces are in place and suddenly
magically the pieces are in place and
I've I now love that feeling
I love sort of jumping off to see like
okay am I gonna is something gonna catch
me and nine times out of ten it does and
when it doesn't I'll I'll figure it out
and it's just been a that's been a
recurring theme throughout my whole life
it's just if you're afraid of it you
have to do it so I'm taking a quote that
you have here I met my best when I'm
telling extremely personal stories mmm
would you say you're an open book you're
okay with people knowing things about
you absolutely yeah I I like to in fact
I I try to challenge myself to be even
more open I don't feel like I'm as open
as I need to be and what I mean by that
is like I I've always had like sort of
an outsider perspective growing up and
I've always felt like I have a reservoir
of almost like pain and truth from which
to draw from and I've noticed that like
whenever I'm telling stories that aren't
very personal there's like something
kind of missing about it there's like
there's like it's almost like an athlete
in the fourth quarter who doesn't have
their legs under them you know I mean to
shoot a jump shot but I noticed that
when I when I really lean into my truth
and I lean into the things that mean a
lot to me and lean into the things that
have value and things I can talk about
it at length and just kind of keep keep
going on and seem to never really run
out of energy those are my best
stories that that I tell and I also
think there's something to be sad about
because a professor of mine when I was
at school
he's a it's a Vincent Robert said this
to me he said why do we tell stories and
he asked that one day and everybody in
class was like raising their hands
saying all these different things and we
were all wrong and he said no no we tell
stories to heal that's why we tell
stories and I had a moment where I
I almost couldn't breathe because I
realized he was totally right at least
for me
I realized that's why I tell stories
because there's something about opening
up an old wound trying to heal it in a
way where other people can see it that
absolutely heals them too at least
that's what I've experienced so like in
in in my film my film is all about these
two strangers who are actually brothers
who learned to become brothers that's
what the whole movies about and it's
based on like a true story of of my
actual extremely broken relationship
with my older brother and you know we
both grew up like total opposites like
he I was very much a private-school
try to make straight A's kind of kid and
and my other brother like basically hung
out in the streets and you know had a
very vibrant very successful life in
crime and I just didn't understand it
and I didn't get it and it hurt me for
so so so many years and I knew that like
oh man if I if I tell the story about
that and I can like I can make fun of
myself make fun of all the things that
that are I'll basically make light of
all the things that cause me pain I know
for a fact there's gonna be other people
out there that are experiencing
something similar that can relate to it
because a lot of times when you're super
specific about the things that that
caused you pain
you can achieve almost like a universal
sense of connection with other people
because other people can see themselves
in very specific stories and I knew that
and that was something I learned
throughout school and so like I I've
noticed that every single time I do that
every single time I'm honest and I'm
open I usually connect with way more
people than if I tried to be someone
else or tried to tell someone else's
story that didn't fit me I didn't I
didn't have like a I always have to find
like an emotional end that moves me
deeply to my core something I can speak
about at length and when that happens
whenever I know sort of thematically why
I'm telling the story then I can I feel
like I could make a 10 hour movie about
it you know but yeah so I always try to
tell stories are extremely personal and
try to be as open as possible about it
I'm trying to be even more open about
the just the process of what it takes to
put a movie together and the pain that
goes with that too yeah I think people
respect that honesty cuz a lot of us
don't show different things we just want
to put oh no everything's great I got
this kind of you know that's become this
new term and I feel like we've become a
society of like I got this I'm good and
I'm not you know yeah and the reality is
like human beings we are created for
community like we're not really created
I know our society is very individual
you know we celebrate the individual
like the the accomplishments of the
individual like I did this I'm awesome
you know and you know there's there's
something to that about like living up
to your potential ISM as a person as a
as a creator or whatever it is that
you're doing but I think when we deny
the fact that we need to connect with
other people we do ourselves and
everyone around us a disservice because
something magical happens when when
people open up to each other and you
sort of take a risk and you wanted to
trust another person something kind of
beautiful happens in that and
I think in today's day and age like it's
very easy to like open up Instagram and
look around if you like man everybody's
crushing it but me and in the reality
like we're all super broken people like
all of us are broken there's not one
person on this planet that's not broken
and when you can sort of embrace that
you embrace a part of your humanity and
I feel like if you deny that suddenly
you're you're trying you're running away
from from basically your own
fingerprints the thing that the things
that make you uniquely you and I think
the more you embrace your faults your
weaknesses and and even your strengths
because sometimes there can be shame
involved in embracing your own strengths
just embracing who you are the the good
and the bad only makes you a more
valuable contributing member of society
how does it feel to come here and and
want to tell stories you came from a
town where it was very embracing and a
warm family that welcomes you but do you
feel a sense of of like freedom well now
I can tell them other new stories or is
it scarier or how is that because it
seems like maybe people really knew you
back home and and now not saying that
people don't know you but it's there's
so many people here yeah that it's
different so how is that is that freeing
is it scary is it kind of both or I
think it's a bit of both I think the
only thing that I think this entire
process has has taught me is that to not
have shame in telling stories that
excite you of it might because there
there are some stories I know for a fact
that my mother would hate it if I told
that story or if like oh if I put that
scene in a movie my mom's gonna kill me
yeah but like I've now to the point
where like yes I do know that there are
a lot of stories and me that I I'm
confident we'll probably make someone
mad or
you know who perhaps like my other films
and things like that but the reality is
that like we're all constantly evolving
as people and you know just because
something makes someone uncomfortable
doesn't mean there's not truth in it
because a lot of times I mean I mean we
just right now in our society like we
all we're all running from the truth
I've got a lot of things because it
makes us uncomfortable and I think like
as long as I can find and tell stories
that I feel are authentic to me where I
can lean into truth and embrace it lean
and pain and embrace it then I'm going
to as much as possible aggressively
pursue those types of stories and I'm I
think one thing about perhaps like ever
since ever since I finished my my
feature I think I've really begun to
realize like you know just how much
effort it takes to make a film and how
much how much craft and and work and
sweat and all these different things it
takes to craft a story to where someone
else can enjoy it and and get what it is
you're trying to do that now like for
instance my films moving forward like
I'm gonna make them even more when try
my best to make them even more honest
and even more embrace like the parts of
me that are in the movie more because
with as much effort as you put into
these things like yeah might as well
make them as potent and as sharp and as
resonant emotionally as possible so yeah
why did you feel you need to tell this
personal story what why was it so
important to you because I knew that I
needed to learn how to forgive that's
that's basically as as simple as it as
it as it as can be
really because like my I think for the
majority of my adult life I've harbored
lots of like really mean unfair
feelings against my
there and it's really only been I think
really actually it's it's kind of timed
up perfectly with the making of this
film because now like for instance
before the movie we rarely ever talked
and I probably saw my brother maybe like
once a year
maybe maybe and that was on holidays and
I was just for the free food it's always
for and and I I knew that I wanted to
try to forgive him and I wanted to also
try to forgive myself for not forgiving
him it's like this weird inception like
mind trick but basically I I came out of
film school and I was like I really want
to make a feature what's the most potent
topic I can make a feature about in my
life and I tried to write I wrote all
these other scripts but I realized I was
mostly running away from wanting to talk
about my brother and so the whole thing
was originally designed because like
what I wanted to happen and this would
have been so great it was I I get a kick
out of it but what what was supposed to
happen is I was gonna write a script and
I was gonna play myself in the script
and my brother was gonna play himself
and because I wrote it I could make him
say things to me and I could say things
to him and together throughout this
process we could learn to forgive each
other and hopefully maybe salvage a
little bit of a relationship out of it
that was the that was the whole point
and what was what was crazy is almost
like down to the to the to the day like
I started writing the script and I was
talking to my brother and my brother and
I for the first time started talking
about things I would ask him like hey so
why did you used to do that growing up
or why were you never here what what
were you doing and he kind of opened up
to me and he would start telling me
these things I would take those things
and kind of craft them into a character
and to the script and things like that
and throughout the writing process we
talked more than we'd ever talked before
and almost like clockwork the day that I
finished the script I picked up the
phone to call him and his number was
disconnected and I was like what's going
on and so I called my mom and my mom was
like oh you haven't heard
he went on the run from the police and
so he just disappeared and so I was like
oh man okay
Wow and it was weird because I kind of
knew it would happen like I knew that uh
stalking consistently wasn't something
it was probably gonna continue to happen
at this point in our in our relationship
and before I knew it he was gone and so
we went and made the movie kind of in a
more I don't want to say legit cuz it's
like extremely micro-budget
but uh but we you know hired actors and
like suddenly was gonna be a thing and
before that I was just gonna be
basically me and him and like a DP and
that's it
that's what that was what the whole
thing was designed to do and what was
wild though is like after we finished it
was almost like it was almost like we
almost synced up in this weird way like
we weren't in connection but like when
when our movie got into post-production
like at one point all of our financing
fell through and so I was doing post
just by myself it was like me and one of
my friends doing post and so the movie
like you know went to a crawl and while
that happened like that while that
happened like I found out my brother was
he gotten caught and he went to prison
and so it's weird cuz I felt like I was
trapped in post when my brother was
trapped in prison that's that's what it
felt like and then the craziest thing
happened at one point like the finance
so the financial end got taken care of
in terms of posts and then suddenly
things sped up again and around that
time my brother got released early from
the prison on a work release program and
so he basically got out of prison and
then he was sort of in the sort of
incubating period where all he had to do
was was he had to get a job and he had
to report to certain parole officers and
things like that and so like we I
finished the movie almost exactly around
the time he got out of out of prison and
what was fascinating is like because he
had gone through this really rough
experience and I had gone through a
creative lyrics
we both kind of met up again and like
our relationship kind of picked up right
right where it left off and it was
beautiful
and he saw the movie and he saw himself
in the movie and saw how I felt about
him in the movie in like we cried about
it and like and since then this is like
what seven months later we text every
day we call each other every other day
and we talk frequently and my brother
now like he's completely turned his life
around he's got a got a great job and
you know he's being a father to his
children and it's a beautiful thing and
I really do think that that our whole
family coming together to tell the story
of that is my feature then there was Joe
I think that truly healed my family and
I can I can say that unequivocally like
I mean it totally brought my family
together in a beautiful way and so I I
do know at least the power of movies to
at least heal my family and that's a
real thing and that was a very beautiful
thing that I don't think could have been
planned it just happened serve
serendipitously and it was beautiful and
so I do know like first hand that that's
why I tell stories I tell them to heal I
know you said you screened the film at
the Arkansas cinema Society and was your
brother there he was it was amazing
because it what we weren't sure if he
was gonna be able to make it he actually
had to get like you know permission to
actually show up and do it but he was
there he was in the second row and that
it wasn't the first time he had seen it
because we watched it we watched it
together before that but he was there
and it was it was amazing because he was
laughing almost harder than anyone else
was laughing in the movie which was
great and then afterwards like it was
amazing because the REA Grady who's the
actor that plays my brother who was
phenomenal in the movie got to meet my
actual brother and it was an amazing
experience seeing both of them together
because like I cast ray Grady because
is the essence of ray Grady reminded me
more of my brother than any other human
being I'd ever met in my whole life and
so to see both of them together was
mind-blowing it was awesome it was
incredible and they were like kindred
spirits
they were like joking and and like they
had always been friends it was amazing
it's a really cool experience when you
approached your brother about writing a
film about your family how did he take
that yes
so what's funny is like I actually think
I get my openness I get a piece of it
from my brother as well so my brother
has never been shy about his lifestyle
in fact he kind of flaunts it and that
was kind of a way to him to sort of
exhibit his power like he would come
home sometimes you know and would just
not hide like what I where I've been
what I've been doing and he would just
kind of like be like yeah I was over at
substance of this house and we were
doing this and you know my mom would
gasp she's like what what you know and
he would like kind of like grovel and
that to some degree you know and so when
I was like hey I want to I want to make
a movie kind of about us he was like
that's awesome so it was totally down
with it which is like so it and and like
really encouraged me to go for it and
it's funny now I feel like I I didn't
push the film far enough in a lot of and
a lot of areas like there were there
were lots of things I was like oh man
this is too much I think this is too
much and and my brother would would I
tell him I hey I'm gonna put this in the
movies like yeah so he's like you like
you need to push that and I've got no I
already feel like that's it's kind of a
lot already and you know so so the
actual like back and forth process like
they like he was totally down with it
like I didn't have to feel like I had
like win him over or anything like he
was really really rooting for me which
was crazy because I was kind of the
first time I felt in my life
I'm sure he's rooted for me in other
areas of my life but in
this particular arena I felt more than
ever that he was cheering for me and I
think that kind of opened me up to him
even more to be like oh well he wants me
to do this he supports me in doing this
and I think that was like a little
doorway into the healing process when
you made that phone call and the number
was changed
what was that day like it's weird I
almost felt like I was expecting it and
and the reason why I say that is because
like I've I sometimes can have a
tendency to be very cynical and be
extremely pessimistic sometimes and I
every single time I get off the phone
with him I'd be like that's probably
last time I'm talking to him I don't
know what I'm talk to him again and
whenever I'd call him and he would
answer I would be shocked I'd be amazed
I'm like oh my god he picked up the
phone he answered my call because that
historically has never been the case
ever from anything that we've done and
so I I was just like yeah one of these
days one of these days I'm gonna call
and he's not gonna pick up or one of
these days I'm gonna call he's gonna say
don't ever talk to me again I don't know
maybe or something but so when it
happened I was kind of ready for it and
it didn't really shock me that much but
I was sad I was sad because like during
that probably that probably like
six-month process of talking to him back
and forth was the most I'd ever talked
to him so it was it was really cool and
that regards were actually starting to
like develop a rapport and it kind of
felt like we were brothers for a little
bit which was really great and then that
was kind of like suddenly not in my life
and it was painful but but I think for
the most part I I was prepared
so did you kind of have this thing in
the back your mind that well then maybe
I'll hire actors yes yeah
because also that there were a lot of
things that I was I was as we kept kind
of getting closer to to the script
getting done and actually thinking about
the logistics of making a film because I
think a lot of people if you're not if
you don't work in
you don't realize how long the hours are
and just how like crazy it is a lot of
times to shoot a film and so you know my
my brother at the time wasn't exactly
totally reliable so you know to have him
show up 12 hours a day to shoot
something 10 hours a day however my long
we would shoot for would have been a
stretch for him it would have been a big
challenge for him and so we were I was
about to start pivoting the conversation
to that about like hey you know if we do
this and like I have friends come over
to shoot this like you you got to show
up you actually have to be there for
that and and like for a really long time
and you know like it would be really
great if you don't leave in the middle
of it to go do something else and come
back whenever you feel like it like it's
it's it's gonna be pretty hardcore
and I was about to have that
conversation with him and that's around
when like we we lost touch and so I kind
of knew at some point that like I knew I
would be casting other characters anyway
and so the idea of casting him I did
like at the time I was bummed that I
would have to do that but I'm really
really glad that we ended up doing it
that way in so many ways cuz I think
that my brother seeing the film pretty
much totally objectively like another
person being him actually allowed the
allowed the movie to do more of what it
was designed to do does it make sense
yeah because if you're in it it's it's
easy just to look at you in the movie
but if there's someone else portraying
you in the movie it's a totally
different experience it's removed and so
I think he got to experience it that way
like he's like oh that guy portrays me
that's not me that's a guy portraying me
and that character is written by that
guy so that must be what he thinks of me
and that's you know I mean and so right
it was like a really fascinating
experience and I wouldn't change it at
all now
because I think it worked out great and
like like I said ray Grady who pray who
plays my who plays a version of my
brother in the movie like we kind of
became brothers while we were shooting
the film and you know we have a very
sort of like brotherly rapport and that
was that was something like an
unexpected gift from the from the
production and so that's something I
wouldn't change but it was a yeah I
wouldn't change a thing it happened not
and turned out great if you don't want
to answer this we can turn it off but
this wasn't the first time that a film
crew had followed your family or are you
okay oh yeah I wasn't sure so could you
talk about that and that this film crew
that follows your family yeah yeah so
about I guess it was oh my god almost 11
years ago now in 2007 my family was
featured on cnn's black in America and
so it was wild because I was like my
family's first brush with like show
business and so CNN like sent camera
crews down and they followed my family
around for a few months actually it was
it was pretty crazy like at one point
like there were there were camera crews
following me around in college which was
weird it was weird and at the time I had
no babe skills but when you walk around
with that and he got cameras right so
been like okay yeah yeah right right and
so so that whole process was like really
it was pretty fun actually but like
there was a and there's a part in the
documentary where it where it brings
that up where it like just the irony of
the vodka so my mother's a juvenile
judge my dad was super high up in the
school district in Arkansas and my
brother is an attorney and I was at the
time I would want to be a musician
that's what I want to do so it's playing
music and playing shows and stuff like
that and then suddenly you've got this
this guy who you know goes to prison
basically for you know goes on trial for
shooting somebody you know that's pretty
wild
pretty it's like how did that happen you
know and so like they that was kind of I
I think actually in hindsight I think
that was kind of
the first instance where I was like oh
that is pretty weird that you know like
you've got these pretty respectable
upstanding parents they have three kids
two of them kind of go and go this way
and one of them goes like that way and
that was kind of one of the first times
where I realized that that situation was
interesting or unique or there was
potential there and so you know I I
guess if CNN found it interesting I was
like okay I guess that might be
interesting so maybe I should look into
that and so so it is fascinating like
years later to kind of look and realize
like oh yeah that thing that they were
kind of they kind of that resonated with
them you know has has been my story my
whole life and that was the first time
where I kind of realize like oh that is
pretty different that's like a kind of a
twist something I could I could use and
you know at the time it was weird too
because my brother was in a in a place
where he wasn't open with with that
particular instance that occurred now
he's pretty open about it and he'll talk
about it but I know at the time like all
the controversy surrounding that because
when that when my brother basically shot
someone in an Arkansas he did not kill
them they didn't die there they're alive
and well they like that was like really
controversial at the time in my small
hometown where I'm from and so at the
time he didn't want to talk about it at
all now he's he's fine too you know he's
owned up to it and things like that like
he's he's fine now but uh but at the
time I remember there was a lot more
tension in my family when we were
filming the the CNN thing then there was
now like when we shot then that was Joe
because at that point we we kind of just
knew that like yeah that that's that's
what that's my brother's lifestyle
that's what he does
and so I was able to sort of see it more
objectively
you know 10 years later than at the time
because at the time I was just mad at
him so and sometimes when you're mad
it's really difficult to see anything
objectively I think when you're when
you're angry you can't see anything
objectively and so later on the anger I
think turned more into just pain and
pain to some extent is more objective
than anger I think because you can have
a wound you're like man this really
hurts why does it hurt but when you're
angry you're like this hurts I hate
everything you know and that's really
difficult to to objectively begin the
healing process when you're angry so
yeah how many people saw that news story
and how long was the piece that they did
the piece was well I I know they did
like three I think they did three
segments they did like the black man the
black family and then the black
something else but my but my dad was
basically this like the main subject in
the black man and that was the I think
the first one that ran it was an hour
piece that they ran and the what was the
other question
oh do you know how many people saw um it
was I know it was in the millions I
don't know how many millions I've heard
like my dad can sometimes embellish
things and and he said I I think he said
like like 25 million people had seen it
but I do know for a fact that that like
at one point after it aired we got a
message from one of our family friends
in Cairo she was in Cairo and saw it on
TV
and she was like I'm looking at your dad
on TV in Cairo and I was like whoa and
that was on the the first I was like oh
wait people actually saw like people saw
that you know because in my brain like
whenever I I guess I always convinced
myself is like I know he's gonna see it
it's fine you know but like I guess a
lot of people did see it which is pretty
cool so it's cool and it's cool to have
the camera I'm sure hit your college I
mean that sounds pretty interesting
that does sound cool but then some of
that fades I'm sure after a while did
you have
feel like well I kind of wish some of
this would go away or were you okay with
that because there was a deeper meaning
for wanting to do it yeah it actually
like faded away pretty quickly like I
mean it seemed like there was all this
hoopla and then it aired and it was over
I was like oh okay back to our normal
lives and like it didn't I didn't feel
like there was like I know I've never
had a mo more like no no cameras please
no cameras it's never happened and like
so so basically like after was over it
was just like okay now everything's back
to normal
and which I think was good I think that
was a good thing because like I I think
potentially as impressionable as I was
because I'm 31 now and I was 21 then or
I was about to turn 20 I was about to
turn 21 I think that if like the hoopla
had continued it may have gotten to my
head maybe I don't know like just as
impressive as I was back then but I'm so
I'm kind of glad it didn't didn't seem
to like the buzz didn't continue for a
really long time so but not just go to
your head I meant more like they know
your personal story and oh how is that
because it's something you live with
every day and your family lives but to
know that you could be going to the mall
and there could be like yeah what's
what's weird is like I that that doesn't
really ever bother me and I I don't know
if I was just not born with that muscle
in my brain but like you know I guess my
my story being being public doesn't
really bother me because it's what
happened you know and I I don't think
CNN portrayed it in like a bad way
so it was very objective it was very
like factual well yeah that's pretty
it's pretty right that's what happened
so and like my my family's never really
been one to like try to hide things it's
like yeah it happened and so I've always
kind of I think I got that mostly from
from my parents because my you know my
mom has just been a public figure for
you know 35 years and so like
my family at least in Arkansas where I'm
from as like frequently in the paper and
on the news and things like that so you
know when some sort of controversy
happens or something and it becomes
public like we've always just been like
yeah that that happened and you know
this what we can learn from it and this
how we move on and so I guess I guess
when I'm talking about this now I think
it kind of primed me for you know making
then there was Joe because it's like it
was a I know that there are some
segments of my family that did not want
me to tell a story about my family at
all
because I I do think I'll in any others
there's some valid there's some validity
to it like where you know there's some
shame sometimes associated with things
and if you're not over that shame you
don't want people you know shine and
lights and cameras on your shame you
know but fortunately I I think that I
was able to look at it pretty
objectively and so was my brother and so
when we actually made the film it kind
of felt kind of felt like yep we're just
like we're just exercise our demons here
it's all we're doing nothing to see you
know and I think that that was like the
best way to to tell that story in
particular and it's it's it's given me a
lot of bravery to face other areas of my
life that I perhaps looked upon with
shame to just be like nope we all have
we all have you know there's one in
every family type thing you know and
like we all have pain we all have
brokenness and if we can stand up and
sort of like offer that to the world in
a way where other people can experience
it like I've only found that good things
happen with that do you ever get stuck
do you ever get stuck sometimes
and I realize when I get stuck it's
because I'm afraid that's usually the
only reason I get stuck or I I and
because a lot of times I think when when
we get stuck for me what when you said
stuck I thought like just creatively
stuck and yeah I think almost all the
time like we
you're stuck it's like an intersection
of of lack of information and fear and
those things cross and then that stuck
and then for me I've noticed that like
there's this writing mentor that I I
love very dearly his name is John voir
house and he writes a lot of these books
about creativity and like what that you
know kind of like mentally what's going
on in the brain of a creative and almost
nine times out of ten when you're stuck
it's because you are at an intersection
of lack of information and fear and so
when I when I get stuck and a lot of
times like I all right I try to be very
like almost like scientific about my
writing process and I like to like
measure my goals and like how many pages
should it right today and things like
that and I try to be very measurable
about it so I can because I love to feel
progress so whenever I don't feel
progress I have sort of a mini freakout
and then I start to realize oh it's
because I for this creative problem I
don't have enough information or I'm
scared and so and one of the best things
to do to alleviate fear is to at least
for me because I'm obsessive-compulsive
I I make lists
so I list things so for instance like if
I'm having a difficult time figuring out
what happens next in a in a script of
mine I'll sit down nothing like okay
well the answer is here I just can't see
it right now so what I need to do is I
need to study what is here and generate
enough information to just dislodge
something in my brain so I can move
forward so if it's like you know if it's
like okay I don't know how this guy gets
gets the lightsaber he's got to get a
lightsaber something okay well where is
he
he's in a he's in a he's in a building
okay what kind of building is it's an
office building
okay well let's list everything that's
in an office building until we figure
out oh like oh yeah I didn't realize
that office buildings have staplers in
them maybe he could take the stapler and
then staple this thing and then that
dislodges that and then boom the
lightsaber pops out boom solved
that's a terrible example but I've I've
taken that that sort of problem-solving
angle to getting a stuck and I've
applied to almost every area of my life
so Fritz is like there was a there was a
time where I was like really frustrated
because like I really wanted to get like
more more screenings of my film on the
books right and and then I had a moment
I was like oh well I can just sit here
and make a list of all the places in the
world that might be interested in
screening my movie and you do that and
you keep going and you will end up with
a list that is absurd absurdly long and
then that sort of starts to take away
fear because I think fear comes from a
mindset of scarcity and so when you
realize and you sort of take your eyes
off of that and look at the abundance
there's opportunities there are
solutions there are for me I'm a comedic
filmmaker so there are jokes there all
that is everywhere it's everywhere and
it's all just a matter of focus and
attention so if you're scared about
something and there's no shame and being
asked of being afraid because fear is a
very real thing but what I try to do is
I just try to take a systematic approach
to alleviate my fear I try to identify
what it is and I try to solve it like a
like a math problem what word do you
feel you use too much when you're
writing and then you go back and you
look at it and go oh I keep using that
word what word or words
probably staggers oh really it's really
random but like you know when it comes
to writing like I'm very anal retentive
about like which verbs I pick you know
because like strong verbs are visual in
there they're active and you know a lot
of times like that can eliminate the
need for an adverb so you just pick a
really strong verb so I'll be like Bob
staggers into the room and stumbles over
a couch or something like that you know
and then I'll go back I'm like I use
staggers and stumbles a lot I should
probably like find another
verb for that I know it sounds really
weird and really random but like I've
noticed that in a lot of my first drafts
I'll use the word staggers a lot yeah I
picture like John Wayne staggers out of
the saloon right cigarette down and get
me another whiskey okay so that seems to
be a favorite word but then you try to
take it away cuz you see you use it yeah
I use it too much I also I probably well
I don't know no I don't know if you can
but like an in screenwriting in
particular I like I use so many double
dashes it's crazy in double dash it's
not a word but like I I feel like if you
were to just find and replace double
dashes it would like probably make the
computer explode there's just too many
of them but I like it because I like
forces meeting you know embrace
whitespace and all that good stuff but I
but yeah probably staggers interesting
what words do you feel are overused in
writing today huh overused pretty but
doesn't know it like that's a phrase not
that a particular word but I agree I
think that phrase gets used a lot
she's pretty but doesn't know it it's
like I don't know what that means
like I don't know I don't know what that
means and that's a very like male
perspective you know I mean but I see
that a lot in in scripts is pretty but
doesn't know it a woman would say pretty
but she's nice right pretty much she's
nice yeah yeah exactly but yeah I see
that phrase used a lot you know I've
actually tried to in the last like year
or so make my scripts more
conversational instead of more like
right early if that makes sense like
they're right early in the sense of like
the words are scrutinized of of like
what words appear on the page and what
words more importantly what words don't
appear on the page but I try my best to
like almost make it like Justin's
telling you a story because you know a
lot of times like you know I hate to say
this but most people don't read anymore
you know I mean it's like really hard to
get people to
read to read anything even like your
close friends it's really hard to get
people to read and I get it I get it
because like where we're all so busy
with things that to actually carve and
set aside long stretches of time
especially to read a screenplay and it's
like a hundred words 100 and I'm you
sorry 100 pages 120 pages sometimes
which is pretty long these days so I try
to make the the script as fun to read as
possible so so if I'm fortunate enough
and somebody's it's generally it's my
script they're like oh it kind of felt
like you were talking to me and it kind
of felt like a friend was telling you a
story so I've tried to do that more and
I've I've had a modicum of success with
that but I am yeah so when you say you
try to make it less writerly is that the
dialogue it was just it's more like
grunts like yeah it's okay instead of
like yes I had a wonderful time yeah
yeah like I definitely try to make the
the dialogue because like you know I
there's some there's a lot of different
modes of thought of like Oh a character
should never repeat themselves or you
know something like that but the ratleys
people repeat themselves all the time
you know like in the middle of talking
like sometimes people can repeat
themselves and so like what I do a lot
of times and this comes from my my a
theatre degree my theater background is
like I actually say the dialogue out
loud and whatever I say that feels
normal I write that down so if there are
ohms and oz in it and those arms and oz
feel natural and feel like that's how
this particular person would say I write
them in it into the actual dialogue and
I think that like if you know if I'm
doing my job properly it should feel
like these are actual human beings
talking because an actual human being
said that you know and I think sometimes
when you become sometimes you can be to
write early in the sense that the
dialogue can sometimes be too clean and
too sterile to a degree where it feels
like it's written instead of something
that should be experienced if that makes
sense so I've tried to like allow myself
that freedom and that you know I don't
know if I've I can say I've earned that
luxury yet but I feel that that works
for me
do you have a favorite dialogue scene in
the movie that you just love the
dialogue it's
some people say well Harry wouldn't
Harry Met Sally or you know whatever
there yeah that's gonna sell for that
100 that's that's that's a really great
question
the apartment is when my favorite movies
ever ever made and you know the I've
always loved there's like a scene where
like Jacqueline and and shirley maclaine
are like he's putting on a bowler hat
and the and in that scene there's a
moment where he like flips flips open
this compact and the compact is
shattered and because it's shattered he
knows that like oh that girl that I have
a crush on my boss also likes and in
that moment and like the dialogue in
that scene is so witty and so charming
and so beautiful but also it's
heartbreaking because like he's still
trying to the second that he realizes
that Shirley MacLaine he probably can't
have her in that moment that's what he's
feeling he still like keeps his
conversation like you know light and
witty but he's feeling pain while he's
doing that and I've always loved that
scene in particular I also love the
dialogue in Boogie Nights Boogie Nights
some of my favorite movies of all time
like there's a scene where like Don
Cheadle is is trying to sell this guy
this the stereo system and he's got like
this this country twang and it's it's
amazing it is so good and to me though
like those characters just feel lived in
they feel real they feel very specific
to what they are in the degree of like
they are they're just memorable and I
really really like stuff like that so I
don't that answer the question
here is this lovely bag okay great cool
awesome
I will just pick one at random okay
great
by the way weird can we purchase this
bag it's on my website okay
just kidding it's my wife's make it back
okay cool this is from Andry salve
Jenko okay hurry I'm sorry I know I
butchered your name yeah but I
appreciate your question hi what was the
biggest obstacle on your way in the
whole process and how were you able to
get through it
thank you Andy okay Oh Andrey up here oh
it might be a typo okay so it's Andy
Andy Savchenko okay thank you for your
question thank you what's the biggest
obstacle on my way in the whole process
and how were you able to get through it
surprisingly I think like the at least
for me in my in my feature film I think
the biggest obstacle was really just
fear yeah and you know that's a very
like that might sound like a cop-out
answer but it's it's really not i think
the the hardest part is like trusting
yourself throughout the madness of
everything that's going on like the one
of the biggest fears i had was just like
trying to come up with the money for it
because that was a really difficult
process like we did a Kickstarter
campaign and we raised $35,000 for it
which was really I think I had a little
bit of beginner's luck because when I
look back at it now I kind of can't
believe that we did that it's pretty
wild but like I think the the hardest
part
it's it's really the fear and also the
patience it takes to sort of do one of
these things because things are never
gonna move as fast as you want them to
move they're gonna move about like one
of the things I realized is like almost
everything that I thought I was yeah I
should have had done a month I just
started multiplying it by four so
everything like that's what we done in a
month and we take four months because
because working at this level because my
film is a micro budget film you know
basically like you know there's a
there's like a that triangle right like
the good fast and cheap triangle you can
only have two of them that is a real
thing that's totally a real thing and so
if you don't have the money to do
something and you are having someone
work on it like well they're probably
only gonna work on it like when they
have time to do so
and that means that you can get it good
but it's not gonna be fast and so like I
noticed that because like a lot of like
I think we we did like really really
great work on my film and the people
like all the different disciplines did a
great job but it just took a really long
time and I think that the patient's can
almost be enough to drive you mad like
for instance our our our VFX guy who's a
brilliant VFX artist and he works at
like this big VFX house was basically
working on my film at nights every other
weekend cuz he had stuff to do when he
just had a brand-new kid and things like
that so like that took a long time you
know my my dear friend who's a sound
designer did sound on my film but he was
working on that throughout all all of
his different jobs so that was a super
slow process so I think just being
prepared with how with the patience like
how long it's gonna take
you'd be surprised I get like waiting
waiting for something can drive you mad
especially if like that is like your
number one focus which is which is your
feature or or your project that you're
working on because it's only gonna be
it's only gonna burn with that level of
intensity to you the creator it's not
gonna burn with that same level of
intensity to anybody else and knowing
that and embracing that can allow you to
be cool with it and like I think earlier
during the the post-production process
like I didn't understand that and that
would I would get angry and I would get
like very impatient and I would I would
be confused like why aren't they getting
back to me what's going on look look I
can't take it you know and which is just
silly you know because the reality is
that like any
that's that is good takes time you know
there's a I think the quotes from like
Alice in Wonderland but there are no
shortcuts to place is worth going that's
a real thing you know like we live in a
culture where we want things we want it
now
and we want things instantly but when it
comes to making something like like a
feature or just any sort of long-term
project it just takes time and takes
time for the thing to to develop it
takes time for the thing to marinate and
the patience and getting through the
fear of it are the two biggest obstacles
I'd say so this question comes in from
Michael Pythium hi Michael by the way
thank you for your question definitely
an awesome feat but what drives you was
it always a dream to be a filmmaker or
was it something that fell into your lap
one day yeah I think it's somewhere in
between those two things I think I'm an
I'm an odd case in the sense of like I
had always grown up like my friends is
like what like when I was 8 years old my
my grandfather gave me a VHS camera and
so I had the first movie I ever made was
like I I made r2d2 crawl across my roll
across my kitchen table using
stop-motion animation I was the first
movie I ever made when I was 8 years old
and I I pretty much always played with a
camera growing up because I was pretty
lonely I didn't have a lot of friends so
I would stay at home on the weekends and
I would make I would literally play I'd
make little Star Wars films and I would
play all the parts I would and I
intuitively sort of understood it like
okay well I like I would cut all the
everything in camera because it was like
before I had access to like Final Cut or
anything like that so like I would like
actually film like me as like a Sith
Lord going like don't you know where are
the rebels and then I'd stop and then
turn it and then I'd take the mask off
and then go over here and then be the be
the other side of the conversation
right so that had always been in my life
but I never like wanted
FileMaker growing up I just did it
because that's how I entertain myself
and then you know I went to I went to
college and in college I was I was
pretty hell-bent on becoming an actor
that's what I really wanted to do and a
musician I really want to do those two
things and so I ended up sort of at some
point realizing like maybe I confuse
those two things together and figure out
a way to use all these different
interests into one thing because the
thing I love about filmmaking is like
it's like so many different disciplines
all married into one thing and so I
wasn't ever really gonna pursue it
really until I got into film school and
I got into film school I was telling you
earlier like it kind of blindsided me I
didn't expect to get in I didn't know I
didn't know anyone there I did you know
I like on I feel like on paper there's
no way I should have gotten into film
school there's just no way and so I sort
of took that almost as like you know as
this weird is gonna sound weird but
almost like divine you know intervention
of like you need to do this and it's
something I've always been fascinated by
and so I went to film school basically
because like my school wouldn't allow
anyone to defer like it's like a once in
a lifetime chance it's like you're
either in or you're not in because I was
gonna see like maybe I can defer a year
or something like that and that wasn't
an option and so I just jumped and did
it and because it sounded way better
than working for a gas company so I I've
done that and now I can't see my life
without creating films I can't see it
and so there was never really a moment
where I was like I want to be a
filmmaker and this is what I'm gonna do
it did kind of fall into my lap but
that's because I had all it always sort
of been in the background in the way you
know and in movies were always a way
that my thing
we bonded together like we speak in
movie quotes to each other you know
that's that's my family my dad's a
massive film buff and so like you know
Turner Classic Movies was always on when
we were growing up and I'd be like daddy
why are your movies in black and white
and minor in color like what's going on
I don't understand you know and like I
don't know it's it's sort of been a
natural progression there was never a
moment where I was like I am a filmmaker
now it's been a real slow burn for me to
kind of get to this point and and now
like writing scripts and and making
films kind of feels like breathing to me
not in the sense of it's easy it feels
just natural it feels like oh this is a
thing I have to do because it's in me
now if that makes sense
it does I was just wondering with this
job that was that the gas company was it
already lined up no it was basically me
like I would pass by like okay I'm gonna
work there and then we're going to cuz
this when I was planning my wedding with
my wife I was like okay I'm gonna work
there and then I'm gonna have that house
and cool we're gonna so then we're gonna
have kids it's gonna be awesome and so
that was my plan like I was gonna I was
like literally putting together a resume
to submit to that gas company cuz I'm
gonna work there and so that's yeah
that's basically how that worked out do
you want to do theater on the side you
know I I've always like I love
performing it's great but I the actor's
life to me is so brutal and at that
point in my life I I didn't think I was
strong enough to do that which is like
to pick up and move to you know if you
want to do theater a lot of times you
pick up and move to New York you know
and try to crash with your friends and
try to make it and at that point in my
life I just wasn't that bold to do that
and so for me film school made sense
because it's like oh well that's kind of
like a safe place I can go I can move to
a new place and there's like structure
and you know I can learn about this
thing because I had always fantasized
about me
a movie and like what would that be like
what would that look like and so getting
tagged because actually like there was a
point right after I graduated from
college where I told my mom I was like
you know what I kind of want to try to
make a movie and she was like oh what do
you need for that and and I was like why
I guess I need a camera and she
literally and like this is a testament
to how how phenomenally blessed I am to
have parents like this my my mom
literally opened up her wallet and she
handed me money and she was like do you
think that's enough and I was like I
think so and so I went and I googled
cameras and stuff like that I was like I
think I'm gonna buy that camera and I
never bought it I never bought it
because I realized I didn't know how I
didn't even know where to begin and I
don't want to take my parents hard or
money and buy something and then never
use it I just didn't want to do that and
so I ended up give me my my mom her
money back so just gave it back to her I
was like thank you so much cool I don't
think I'm gonna do that
and then later on I ended up applying to
film school and when I got in then I was
like oh that makes sense like now I can
go and learn how to use a camera and
learn in my brain that's that's what I
was thinking of like oh I can go there I
can go to a safe structured environment
learn my discipline learn my craft and
then come out and do something that I've
always want to do that's just sort of
always kind of been in the background if
that makes sense
and so the getting into film school at
least to me you know and I'm not I'm not
saying everybody needs to go to film
school it's it's definitely different
for every single person like there's
some print some people who don't need it
me in particular I feel like I needed it
because I did I wasn't bold enough just
to pack out pack up my car and move to
LA and just start making films you know
I just not that personality sure so it
worked out I it worked out great for me
so far I'm so far yeah everybody has a
different comfort level like yeah for
sure
and some people they only feel alive
when they're like risking everything
yeah yeah and there are please
absolutely and there's some people that
are incredible with that they're just
amazing like I have some friends that
that have done that just like literally
dropped everything they were doing and
they drove to LA with like 50 bucks in
their pocket and I'm gonna make this
work and they have wow I'm not that
personality I'm just like no I need to
know exactly how much it's gonna cost I
need to know you know I didn't know
where I'm sleeping you know but you know
I feel like the that spirit though the
the magic of movies and and what stories
can do I think that's in all of us and
you know we all take different different
paths to get there but my path doesn't
isn't gonna look like everybody else's
path but so far like you know it's only
really in hindsight that you can look
back and see that oh that did connect to
that and that connected to this but when
you're going through it sometimes I can
feel like chaos but just in my and my
thirty-one years of living when I look
back in my life I realize like every
single moment in my life where I thought
like oh that was the end that end was
always a beginning and this always
connected to that in a way that I
couldn't see at the time and now I'm I
feel like I'm just now getting to the
point where I can just sort of like live
my life and be like oh this is happening
now
okay and just sort of go with it because
I used to fight that all the time I used
to fight like wait but how does this fit
into my dreams of working at a gas
company how does that fit into you know
and at the time I would stress out about
those things but now like I just try to
I don't want to get too new agey here
but you know I try to just follow my my
bliss you know I'm like oh this feels
right this feels right in my intuition
this is what I'm gonna do now and so far
it's been working out alright
well before I found the gong do you do
you ever think about hey like it's 11
o'clock here if I was back home it would
be whatever to whatever and I'd be
looking out on a courtyard from my desk
you know
and I'd have structure and I'd have
things and I'd have yeah either be the
boss or I'd have a boss to report to
uh-huh and that could have been my
reality not that that's a bad reality
for some people right that's great
absolutely but do you ever think about
that I do sometimes think about lake and
it terrifies me and it terrifies me not
not because like yeah like those people
are crazy it's not like that it's it's
like I even though like right now I feel
like I'm I'm on my path like with
without a doubt I'm unquestionably on my
path and I think that that other path at
least for me if I had done that other
that other type of life it would have
been basically it would have been in
reaction to denying risk denying taking
a risk
whenever I have fleeting moments of
thinking like what could have been I
know that that life at least just for me
would have been a byproduct of a
minimizing risk in my life you know
because like there are some people that
go do that and that's what they're
designed to do that's what they're meant
to do for me I'm I'm not designed that
way I am designed to do this and and the
the great part though is like even
though like you know a career in film is
unbelievably unpredictable and I'm just
at the beginning of mine so I'm still
like trying to figure it out but you
know it's been great because like I've
learned to create a lot of structure in
my life that has allowed me to be
creatively productive and and has
allowed more sanity into my life you
know and I I think I've I can definitely
take cuz I call my brother in fact my
brother called me the other day and he
works in nine-to-five job and he was
like man it must be nice to be able to
do whatever you want I was like I know
it probably seems that way but at Snap
case it's a there's a lot of uncertainty
you know there's a lot of
a lack of lack of sometimes direction
that you can feel but I've I've just
like I'm what I'm four years out of
school and I'm a minute first off I'm
amazed I'm still out here like every
single day I'm like man I'm still out
here that's amazing that's incredible
and and and it's all been by some
beautiful design that I I can't
determine while I'm while it's go on
going through it you know every single
thing has led has perfectly led to the
other thing
even in the times where it feels like
I've gone through or I've been going
through the desert without any water you
know and so it's been a really awesome
experience so far and I can't wait to
see where it goes
and we're rolling minutes out okay great
we'll hand the bag all righty
all right great oops sorry okay great
okay this is from Oh Smeltzer sounds
okay hello the itch for a project or
idea how it feels why you can't stop
thinking about it it's a project that
has to get done what was the first
project like that what was the first
project like that man there's a lot of
projects like that actually
like I have a have a kind of like a hard
drive of scripts that I like I just
desperately want to make but the the
thing that I try to do was find like the
great intersection between that feeling
that he's talking about like the that I
desperately have to make this I want
this to exist I'm ready to lay down in
the train tracks to make this work that
that feeling intersecting with like kind
of like realistic resources of where of
where I am right now and so like you
know I have I have scripts that are like
you know take place in fantasy worlds
where like it would take a phenomenal
amounts of money to like build just the
world you know and I those are scripts I
desperately want to make but I'm just
not at that
level right now so the the thing for me
is like it's kind of have to it has to
tick two boxes and asked to tick that
feeling of just like I have to make this
and is this realistic for me to make
because I think that one of the hardest
things I learned is like the the first
movie because like then there was Jo
which is my feature was actually the
second script that I that I landed on to
want to make after it after school so I
written an entire other feature that I
was like I'm gonna make this one
I'm totally gonna make this one and I
started to it was funny I was I was
talking to a producer friend of mine not
the producer of the movie but a producer
friend of mine and I was saying I really
want to make this movie like what do you
think I should do and they're like first
off you should write a business plan and
I was like oh my gosh no and they were
like and you should budget out the movie
so you know like realistically if he can
make this or not and I like was just
like ah man that sounds pretty awful but
I'll do it anyway
so I sat down in like for like a couple
weeks I doubt this script and I realized
very quickly like this is like a million
dollar movie and and I thought real I
thought just in terms of perhaps
cynically I don't know if it's realistic
is the way to put it but cynically I
thought who would give me a million
dollars to make a movie like who would
do that and I was like I don't think
anybody would do that and so I I was
like okay well I need to try and figure
out something else like a way that I can
like gather at least some amount of
money because every movie costs some
amount of money it's not possible to
make something with nothing you have to
have some amount of money and so I was
like okay well I'm gonna do everything I
can to write something that has that
feeling of like I have to make this
along with something that to where it is
also cost-effective so I so then I wrote
then there was Joe thinking like okay
I'm gonna shoot this back home where I'm
from I'm gonna shoot it in my parents
house
where I grew up I know for a fact that
there's a guy down the street who owns
this place he'll probably let us shoot
there for free
you know and so that's what I was
thinking in terms of like how to how to
get it made and so if I tried to do that
with the other film I think I'd still be
trying to make it I'd still be trying to
come with the money like because to be
frank I'm you know like I'm still a
first-time filmmaker like I just
completed my first feature I'm still
like who would give me what if you're
like I don't know you know and so like
I'm still sort of in that mindset of
like okay well I know for a fact I want
to make something else it has to it has
to resonate with me in it and right now
where I am it has to be made in a way
that is realistic like where I'm still
gonna be calling in favors most likely
I'm you know I think for this for my
next film I think I can get a larger sum
of money but not too much you know and
and knowing that like my my goal
eventually just so like stair-step my
way into it you know like each film just
gets a little bit bigger than the last
one which is like that's not too
unreasonable you know if you go from I
think sometimes it's easy to think like
oh man you know I made this movie now my
next one is gonna be a thirty million
dollar movie or something like that and
I maybe I'm cynical but I just think
that's unrealistic maybe that happens
for other people actually does happen
for other people but I don't know if it
would happen for me so my goal is just
to make to make films that that I feel
like I have to make that are within a
certain contained that can be made in a
relatively contained way and what's
great about that too right now I was
like you know I was when I was thinking
about that that first script that I
wanted to make that was like a million
dollars now in hindsight I would never
trust just in two years ago
with a million dollars I would never do
that because like I just didn't have the
chops then I feel like now I could
probably do that
baby I think you know but like it's it's
just one of those things where I feel
like you know filmmaking especially like
directing and writing is like it's a
process to get up to to direct a big a
huge movie you know and I'm just gonna
slowly kind of just March my way
hopefully up the stairs until eventually
I'll get to direct something really big
one day but until then yeah I'm gonna
keep trying to make films within my
means that scratch both of those boxes I
think it's great that you you wouldn't
be so tempted I mean who wouldn't want
two million to make something but I mean
so many people have over confidence I
think sometimes it's kind of this this
thing that's that's definitely like
embraced mhm and I think that's great
that it's that you want to take you want
to kind of go to these next levels in a
progression not not just totally jump
yeah yeah because like I think if I were
to just jump to a huge movie right now
like I don't know how good that movie
would be you know cuz like there's so
many you know it's not a whole thing
like Mo Money mo problems like that's
kind of a real thing you know it's like
so my my last movie was of a certain
very small budget range the next script
that I wrote that I wrote is like about
twice that but that but twice of a
little is still not very much
yeah I mean and I think I can handle
that and I think I can handle that and
make something really solid with in a
very fiscally responsible way and you
know I I like that I like growing i I've
actually learned to appreciate kind of
slow growth and slow progression and
being cool with that because like I was
talking about earlier it's really easy
to want to just get there right now it's
like I want to direct I want to direct
the next Avengers movie right now you
know you can really want that but like
if we're realistic about it like I
wouldn't trust myself right now at this
particular spot in my career I wouldn't
trust myself with it of interest movie
there's no way you know and so and when
I when I get there when I get to the
point where I can direct something like
that's like I want the experience
the resourcefulness to all line up
hopefully in a way that we're synergy is
occurring where I can actually meet that
that opportunity and like do a good job
with it
next question cool thanks okay and this
is from IG lp3 hey there
here's my question oh my name is Chloe
via real hi Chloe
how do you stay the course in spite of
the inner negative narrative so many
writers deal with that says everything
you make sucks that's a good question
oh it's rich it's really rich oh man
goddess Chloe oh man Wow
yeah gosh I feel like I didn't speak on
this for days um I would say like in
particular like how do I get to dark
here but uh but I think writing is
inherently like the only person you're
battling is yourself really most of the
time because and I think in particular
at least for me I can only speak to my
experience but I I struggle a lot with
like self-hatred like I there's lots of
parts of myself that I hate and I'm only
sort of just now getting over a lot of
these types of things but like when it's
just you and a blank screen and a cursor
flashing sometimes like all of your
insecurities and things just bubble up
and it gets in the way of you of you
getting your creative thoughts onto the
page and I've learned just for me like
when I'm able to give myself permission
to write the worst most terrible pages
of all time then I can do it and then I
know in my like in my back pocket I know
that writing is a process so I know that
like whatever I try on my first attempt
is probably not gonna be very good in
fact like you know the the terrible
first draft is like that's just kind of
a law in how I see it
there are other people who I'm sure are
brilliant that can pump out a genius
first draft I'm not that person I will
never be that person and so for me when
I'm allowed to give myself
grace and allow myself to write terribly
too
just write things that don't make sense
to write sentence fragments - right and
then they fight I'll come back later and
then keep going you know what I mean
like when I allow myself that sort of
level of freedom then I can write and I
feel like on paper I shouldn't be a
writer because I'm like my self
criticism in my brain is pretty fierce
and sometimes it's unbearable but I
think that you you do you have to give
yourself grace and you have to like
again I don't want to be too new agey
but you gotta like kind of love yourself
you know what I mean you have to be okay
with yep these are some terrible words
but you know their words and that's all
that matters right now in this
particular instance the only thing that
matters is like I'm putting words onto
the page they don't have to be the right
words and want to be in the right order
but their words and for at least for our
first draft that's the that's the thing
that I think when I learn that sort of
like you know unlocked in my brain I'm
just like oh this draft doesn't count
it doesn't count because I'm gonna I can
go back and fix it later
and so writing with a reckless abandon
of like this doesn't have to be good
this is supposed to be bad anyone can
write a terrible thing you know I mean
terrible just in terms of the mechanics
of the words like anybody can write
something terrible you know and like
that's how I find my entry into it it's
like if all right I know for a fact that
I can write something terrible if my
goal is to sit down and be a genius I
can't hit that every day but I can hit
being really bad every day and so that's
my only metric of success is like are
there words on the page yes I don't my
metric of success is not are they good
words is this good that's for that's for
later sure if I've mentioned this before
but there's this thing called the
dunning-kruger effect and I'm probably
butchering the name of it but I think
it's something to the effect of those
who think that they're really horrible
at something are actually better than
maybe most people I'm not sure I'm put
this concept but then those who actually
think like I'm really good at this
they're actually mistaken and it's this
weird like duality that they're so
people that are actually more I don't
know if the word is like self-effacing
but they actually are better than what
they they think they're doing and then
the opposite is true well I don't know
that's just yeah something that yeah I
think that kind of makes sense I think
there's I think there might be something
to that because you know I think that
you have to be relatively self-aware I
think and well I guess you don't have to
be but I think self-awareness as a
writer is a good thing because you
essentially and and you know but
self-awareness gone unchecked can be
unproductive but if you can like find a
mechanism or a way to where you can use
that as a tool as a way to like be able
to look at something critically but look
at it later
critically that's a really good skill to
have because it allows you to empathize
with people which is really all that
we're trying to do in our stories is
like create empathy between the audience
and the characters that's all we're
trying to do and so that's a I think
that people that might think like I'm
terrible at this I know I'm in that
crowd like I think that can be a
strength when used like a tool you know
used in a very calculated way of like
okay I wrote this thing it's really bad
how can i I know it's bad how can I make
it good how can I do that and that sort
of like not assuming that you have all
the answers to things I think can open
your you up to making much better work
in a long term it reminds me of like the
two characters in adaptation
yeah so you know you see the one he's
the one that feels
and and you know like there's there's so
much but it's just a matter what they
feel is about them yeah is like it's
like just pumping it out yeah it's like
I think I sold this already right nice
you know all these things and it is like
it doesn't make sense but you see that
sometimes in life and you wonder how is
that possible well I think it's
sometimes it's just all of someone's
perception of themselves and it's
absolutely this weird thing yeah yeah
like what you what you think kind of is
your reality you know like if you think
that you're terrible
like you're probably not gonna pump out
you're not probably not even gonna get
the words out you know and so like yeah
when I when I at least for me because I
feel like in in theory I shouldn't be a
writer because I struggle too much with
self-hatred
but I learned yeah I learned that like
if you just give yourself permission to
be terrible you can do it because
everybody can be really bad at something
sure you know it's like you know I think
there's a there's a John Lennon quote or
he's like I'm a musician if you hand me
a tuba I'll get something out of it you
know and like I get that now it's just
like oh he didn't say it would be good
all he said was like I can get something
out of this you know and I think if we
create from that perspective especially
on like first drafts and first attempts
of things you really can't go wrong
because you can anybody can probably get
something out of a tuba yeah my hurts
your ears but right exactly it could
shatter all the glass in the room but
that's okay all righty oh thank you all
right
oh great from flowerpower hey there my
question is how do you get producers to
read your script I don't have any money
or connections how do I approach this
just try to get lucky that's a really
good question I'm still trying to figure
that out but the the one thing that I
have learned is like Hollywood is
incredibly relational in the sense of
like because in theory it's like it's
really bad like I
I used to always think like okay well
why does this writer make it and this
one doesn't like what's the difference
why does this director not and why does
this one not and like the reality is
like it's not it's not fair like life is
not fair in Hollywood in particular is
definitely not fair and like I I don't
mean that to knock it but what I mean is
like basically the I think when I began
to realize that there are no rules then
it sort of opened up for me of like like
for instance I literally heard this
story the other day there was like I I
know this producer friend who got a
movie made literally because he knew
like the stuntman that worked on the
movie with that actor and he asked for
him to pass the script over and somehow
it seems like in theory that should not
work but somehow it worked and so he was
able to attach an actor to his script
and boom it started got made basically
it was like a horror film or something
like that but but uh basically it's like
that's there's no like way it seems like
in my limited experience I've only been
I guess out here total like seven years
but three of that I was in film school
so it's only been about four ish years
I've been trying to crack this this
thing called Hollywood but the I I do
know that like you know and I'm very
introverted so it's like difficult for
me a lot of times like get out and meet
people and so I've noticed though that
when I start becoming more relational
with people things start to happen I'm
not saying that like that means like I'm
gonna be writing on HBO next week you
know but like just I've noticed that
every single year I've been out here I
notice more things that make LA feel
smaller if that makes sense so like for
instance the other day I was watching a
commercial and I saw I saw a friend that
I knew on that commercial and I was like
oh I know him I met him last year that's
him
he's on TV and and then the other day I
was driving down the street and I saw a
billboard and I was like that's Billy
what's really do it you know and it's
it's crazy and every year that seems to
happen a little bit more just a little
bit more and I know that like just
sustained effort over time should
eventually equal breaking into Hollywood
whatever that is you know I mean and so
like I think that you know I definitely
don't have you know an answer to that
but just from my experience I've noticed
that things have started to happen for
me by interfacing and and hanging out
with people who are like-minded who who
you drive with who like you feel like a
connection with because I think a lot of
times you know one of the pieces of
advice a lot of people say is like oh
you got a network just network you know
but networking inherently feels feels
like not relational it feels very sort
of transactional at least in my brain
and so for me I've sort of tried to tip
it to think like okay well I'm just
trying to find other like-minded people
who I connect with and then try to
pursue that great feeling of putting a
movie on the screen or telling a story
or doing something or you know and it's
not just movies it can be anything any
sort of story that moves people like if
we can find a way to connect on that
then we can become allies and we can
fight for each other and you know be in
the trenches together and and that's
been a really beautiful thing so far
since I've sort of taken that that that
approach you know like like I said I'm
still super new at this whole pursuing
filmmaking career stuff but you know I I
do know that I think if if you just
don't give up and just keep meeting
people connecting with people who you
like and they like you back eventually
something is gonna happen like they I
don't even remember what the quote is
but something along the lines of like
you know the people they get lucky
it's like luck is opportunity meets like
preparation you know like that's what
luck is and so like the more
opportunities you have the more people
that you start to get to know that know
what you do and like what you do
eventually there will be an opportunity
for you to be able to step up and do
something you know and and there will be
long stretches of time where nothing
happens and it feels like you're not
making any progress I literally just got
out of a very long stretch of time where
I felt that way where I was just like
what am i doing out here I want to move
back home I am wasting my time it's
super expensive to live out here this is
awful but like something twisted
something turned in my brain I was like
you know what I may not know anybody at
these big studios that can just give me
a movie but I do know a lot of people
out here that are on my level or people
and I'm sorry I shouldn't say level but
who are on their same like same
progression in their journey you know I
know all these people and what I can do
is I can just like connect with the ones
that I feel get me and understand me and
you know I've started that process maybe
like maybe like four months ago and like
it's been amazing
like how many just opportunities have
come from that from just like okay well
I know this writer who was in my class
let's just grab coffee and talk to each
other and see how we might be able to
help each other and that's been
phenomenal like I mean like you can get
your script to people that way you know
another thing that I have a friend who
ended up getting representation because
like she ended up meeting with her
friends that were repped by a rep like
any person who was raped by someone they
went and met with them and like
basically felt it out like is this a
good fit
first like do I feel like I connect with
this person if they did and
and everything seemed right she'd be
like hey it might be a huge ask but like
would you take a look at my script and
not asking hey will you take a look and
give it to your rep just like hey will
you read it and if you like it could you
maybe pass it on if not no harm no foul
and they were they seem to be pretty
successful doing it that way but there's
so many different avenues but there's
really no one way it's Hollywood seems
to be the wild wild west and I think
like at least for me that's what makes
it intriguing of like oh man the the the
next the next thing could come from
anywhere
you know but there is operates there's
way more opportunity around us than I
think sometimes we feel you know it's
only just a matter of focus and
attention like if you focus on the world
being abundant instead of scarce then
suddenly the world becomes abundant and
I've I know it sounds really weird but
like I've noticed what I've made those
conscious choices things seem to happen
all rightie just wind it up here okay
this is from sorry if I'm saying your
name incorrectly a Gabor Rosa hello good
good boy when the movie is done how can
you reach the audience what's the
marketing strategy how do you
communicate with the crowd successfully
great question that's a great question I
have a lot to say about this okay um
well I think that okay and I want to get
to whatever here but okay so I think
that like my marketing strategy has
basically been like I want to build up a
big email list of people that I can then
sell the movie directly to when we do a
digital release later this year that's
been my marketing strategy and the
reason why it's it's like email as
opposed to you know Facebook or Twitter
and things like that is because like the
reality is that like when we when we
think of like what a platform
is a platform is basically a way where
you can where you can reach the people
that you need to reach in a way that
usually is cost-effective and just
effective like in terms of getting
someone's attention and then getting
them to do something right and the issue
at least for for me with like social
media and things like that is I think
sometimes people think that those are
platforms but they're they're really not
though and the reason why I don't think
that those are platforms is because it's
like very very light like for instance
like with with Facebook you know they're
constantly tweaking their algorithm
right and so like you know we've got
we've got a few thousand followers for
then there was Joe we've got twelve
thousand followers for them there was
Joe on Instagram but like such a very
small percentage of those people
actually see anything I post and that's
because of an algorithm an algorithm is
like okay well we can't just post that
and then boom 12,000 people see it and I
think a lot of people think that's how
it works but that's not how it works
and so to me if I have 12,000 people
that have expressed interest and like I
really like that but I can't reach them
and that's not an effective tool to get
their attention and get them to do
something so for me my my strategy is to
yeah is to build up an email list and
because the great part of our email is
email is decentralized like it's not no
one owns email you know it's like email
is like an older technology but from a
time period where like the web was more
open than it is now you know because you
know and and the great part about like
an email list or something because like
if Facebook ever goes under or Instagram
ever goes under which history says they
probably will it could be 20 years from
now it could be 30 years from now but
guarantee you at some point people are
gonna get tired of it's a graham and
there's gonna be a new thing they're
gonna move on to that thing right I
can't take those people with me to this
new thing right but email you can take
anywhere and it
something that you if you build up an
email list you own that list that's
something you can take anywhere and
that's empowering and email has the
highest engagement across any sort of on
the entire internet email has the
highest engagement more than Facebook
more than Twitter all these different
things and so that that is my strategy
build an email list so directly to those
people and I've I've done little small
experiments and it's like phenomenal
it's incredible right so like the you
know my premiere that we had in in
Arkansas for the with the Arkansas
cinema Society with Jeff Nichols we we
sold out that premiere with one email oh
wow I literally sent one emails like hey
guys just won't let you know our tickets
are available you can get them right
here thank you so much see at the show
sold out Wow pretty incredible how many
seats 315 seat oh wow just sold I don't
like that it was pretty amazing it was
pretty cool like with with that email we
sold almost the entire theater and then
like a day later it was sold out was
pretty amazing and like that's that I
think is like if I were to just update
my facebook status that wouldn't happen
it probably wouldn't happen to that
degree you know what I mean
and also like to it stuff like with
these social media platforms like when
you post something you don't really know
who sees it like there's no way of
there's hardly a way to like you know
people can like it and you can see who
likes it but people seeing it there's no
you don't really have access to that
data
you know so it's been that's my that's
that's my strategy it's very simple so
just build up an email list sell the
movie to those people and there's
there's tons of examples of this working
like in publishing right
so like in book publishing that's like
kind of the book publishing model is
like a lot of these authors that already
have massive email subscribers massive
email lists those are the ones that
usually get book deals
it's not the other way around because
now like a lot of these big traditional
companies they look for people who have
already built audiences up and then they
they go hey do you want to do something
together and I think and a lot of times
we look at these things and they because
they used to operate another way it used
to operate like oh that person has
talent cool let's do that well you know
we'll we'll create a band and then boom
they're huge you know I mean but now
it's kind of the other way around it's
like they look and see who's already
huge and they're like okay cool
we can take them and put them to the
next level you know and so I think that
audience building crowd building
whatever sort of building that you know
whatever we want to call it these days I
think like in many ways I think it's the
future and a lot of ways like to gather
your own crowd that you can talk to in a
way that is cost-effective and extremely
effective in terms of getting someone's
attention and being able to gather all
the people around you that are
like-minded in the sense of like they
like your work I think that's really
powerful and I think that the the world
is only going to move further in that
direction
over time it's gonna be the people who
successfully build their audiences in a
way that like those people very much pay
attention to them you know and like and
for some people that's that's not that's
not email but you know there's some
people who you know if you're a Kevin
Hart and you've got 40 something million
people on Instagram or so or something
it's like you're gonna reach a pretty
huge chunk of those people when did you
start building your email list and how
yeah so I started building my email list
about a little over a year ago and like
I've learned it's very difficult to get
people's email addresses for them to
willingly give them to you cuz that's
the that's the magic like they have to
be like yes I opted in to
this thing and you know it's been a
really slow process but we've we've
gathered a decent amount considering how
many people we have on like social media
and stuff like that like we have about
1,500 people our email list now just
like okay you know it's just hard to get
emails sorry it is yeah it is hard yeah
it's super it's super tough but like I I
think that there are ways that there are
definitely ways to accelerate that
process that I haven't explored yet that
I play and explore over the next year so
but it so far it's been it's been like
super effective and way more so than
then getting likes on Facebook or
anything like that I'm not saying that
doesn't have any value but like I have
been able to to you to lot to actually
galvanize my my audience by people more
through that channel through email than
I have through any other channel in what
email program do you use I use MailChimp
okay yeah
just super simple and like I also try to
like make my emails seem like they're
just written by a guy like a just a dude
you know like probably into sweatpants
you know because we can torito's right
it's like probably needs to reapply this
deodorant you know like that's how I
tried it to people you know because like
I think when you get something when you
get something that's like looks like an
official newsletter I think sometimes
people can be like oh it's just from a
thing but like I for me I like when I
think of like I try to imagine it of
like what would it what would I like how
would I like to be talked to if like my
favorite creator was talking to me you
know like if let's say like Charlie
Chaplin was sending emails like how
would I want him to send an email to me
and it'd be like I want to just be like
a regular guy like hey I've made this
thing and you know I trip over some
stuff and you'll like it
you know that's how I would want him to
talk to me so I'd tried it that's how I
try to talk to people just like
there's a dude and they made something
hopefully you like it
you